good morning Hank it's Monday today's
video is like Voldemort soul it comes to
you in 7 parts part 1 Butler Hank my
hometown Butler Bulldogs are the men's
basketball final floor for the second
consecutive year an astonishing
achievement that looked like this at the
bar where I watched the game
I watched all the previous rounds at
home they mostly looked like this
Matt Howard your sister's a nerdfighter
you can hit this free-throw you can yeah
you're ruining it Elmo you're ruining it
by the way Hank Butler star Matt Howard
sister Laura really is a nerdfighter
sports and nerdfighteria Hank the
connections are endless part two
brandishing Hank on Twitter Sammy
semicolon writes I love when at real
John Green brandishes random things like
black Santa's in his videos brandish
brandish brandish part three a
definition Hank it blatantly occurs to
me that some nerdfighters might not even
know what basketball is so let me define
it basically there's two hollow
cylinders in one sphere and you're
trying to put the sphere in one of the
hollow cylinders without having it go in
the other hollow cylinder it's
essentially participatory geometry part
four finalists so make this sparkly
little number Will Grayson Will Grayson
which I co-wrote is a finalist for the
children's book Choice Award Hank actual
teenagers pick the winner of this award
so if you are an actual teenager go to
the link in the doobly-doo and vote for
your favorite book of the year also I
just learned that my new book is
definitely coming out in March not like
in the next two days but you know we got
another March that's gonna come around
that one oh I should probably settle on
a title soon part 5 an imaginary
conversation with LeBron James hi LeBron
James so what do you do for a living I
insert spheres into cylinders wow that
sounds extremely tedious and probably
not very lucrative actually it's
incredibly fun and I make millions of
dollars huh I wouldn't have thought that
job pays well part six titles so Hank
nerdfighteria generated more than two
thousand titles from my new book many of
which were very good but none of which
I'm going to use my original title idea
was to call the book the hectic glow
after the great Thoreau quote decay and
disease are often beautiful like the
pearly tear of the shellfish or the
hectic glow of consumption but the
problem with the hectic glow is that
it's like a rural juror of book titles
you say it and people are like what the
metrics No the hectic blow I don't want
people to think I wrote a book called
the hectic blow then I thought I might
call it omnis cellula you cellula and
the nice folks at penguin were like you
know what doesn't smell like a
best-seller latin so I don't have a firm
title if you have any new suggestions
feel free to leave them in comments part
7 sports it's like life also poop is a
great quote for master
anyway I would argue that sports matter
so like if you're really into Harry
Potter and you got an email from JK
Rowling that would be amazing right like
imagine that moment that would be a
great moment but for some people those
awesome moments are different like the
Cubs winning the World Series are a
bunch of unheralded kids from a liberal
arts school in Indiana going to the
final four Hank we choose what we care
about and while there are better and
worse choices I would argue that caring
about sports has nothing to do with
LeBron James or participatory geometry
ultimately it's about community I'd
argue that caring about sports is
actually a lot like caring about Harry
Potter or Dungeons & Dragons or
nerdfighteria caring about stuff binds
us to the other people who care about
that stuff and that creates the
communities that make life worth living
so Hank that's my defense of sports go
Bulldogs I'll see you on Wednesday